[Music]
debbie is with us in detroit hi debbie
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
my husband and i made a huge mistake we
moved into a houseboat two months ago
and with the housing market being so
crazy and lots of competition for homes
we made a mistake of buying a house for
more than we wanted to spend
we paid over list and appraisal
and
we're now in a house that
we just feel like we can't afford the
mortgage payment
it also has
a pool that is much more of an expense
than we thought it would be
the house
needs a lot of repairs and some things
that come up in the last couple of
months that we didn't realize were going
to need to be repaired right away
so my question is should we
plan on selling it
or
stay for at least two years
um and then not have to worry about
capital gains
but if we sell it now
we would probably
walk away with you know losing about 40
grand
there is no capital gain when you lose
money
right
but an odd chance if we were
if
capital gain would only occur if you
made a profit
right
so it doesn't sound like that's a
problem
yeah
but if we sold it for what we bought it
if we just broke even we'd probably lose
about 40 grand
with closing costs and everything
so what's your house payment
um well that's the other thing too it's
more than what we thought it would be
with um the property taxes are going to
be
more than we had planned for so with
property taxes and insurance about 2300
alone and what's your
monthly take-home pay in your household
about nine thousand okay
all right
well you're slightly above what we would
tell you but not a huge amount
all right it doesn't sound like this
your house payment's not 40 of your
take-home pay
um
this sounds more emotional than
mathematical
okay
because we feel like we've been bleeding
money ever since we moved into the house
because of the pool and the repairs that
have been needed and what have you spent
on repairs
i'm sorry what have you spent on repairs
um
well with the pool it's been
uh
over a thousand dollars
with a repair we just had a garage door
repaired that was over 700.
we need uh what did you pay for the
house
um
we paid 410 for it
and you had
1500 worth of repairs and you're
panicking
yeah
well you make 100 you make 140 000 a
year
yeah well yeah yeah
this is emotional it doesn't sound like
you're bleeding out it feels like you
got a little scrape on the knee but it's
just a lot it sounds like it's more
stress of just we're having a i think
you were super impulsive and you did
something that you wished you hadn't
done and that's what's killing you the
math is not killing you
okay
i mean we shouldn't it's not ideal
yeah but um
i i probably would just breathe a little
bit here um okay you know i i
okay here's the thing the house
payment's not out of control the repairs
are not
eight thousand dollars in one month
there were fourteen hundred in one month
and you make a hundred and forty there's
nothing here that's causing red sirens
to go off and fireworks and panic in the
numbers okay now i understand you have a
deep sense of regret because you feel
like you impulsed and overpaid uh but so
i don't want to trade a 1400 repair and
a house payment is slightly over the
margins we teach which are conservative
for a 40 000 loss
right
well the other thing that i'm worried
about too is um we moved with our jobs
because now we can do our jobs from
anywhere after covid and there is a
chance that my salary could be decreased
based on
where we're living now well if that
happens and you can't afford the house
we can talk about selling it then but we
don't sell a house on what might happen
the house might get hit by a tornado too
yeah but we're not going to sell it
because it might
debbie do you guys have any other debt
other than this mortgage um uh we do
have a car payment um we owe about 12
grand on a car we only have one car and
then we um just from the move we've got
about 6 000 on credit cards
so it sounds like there's some other
pieces to this puzzle that are causing
this stress do you have an emergency
fund
um we have about 25 000 in savings
okay now i would write a check and pay
off the credit card and cut it up and
pay off the car today
right okay and you guys need to get on a
budget you are not in control with your
spending
that's where the stress is coming from
the sense of chaos is where the stress
is not the actual math there was more to
it i think she's bleeding out more from
these payments versus the mortgage and i
think once she gets that out of her life
they pay down the debt they refill the
emergency fund she's gonna breathe and
go okay no car payment no credit card
and be on a written plan with every
dollar where you know you're under
control
both you and your husband looking at the
numbers every month stress level goes
down
then if you want to sell the house when
it's not a forty thousand dollar loss
four thousand dollar loss maybe